Speaker 1: If the FBI hasn't already, it really
should open an investigation into radical
Trampas Magga, Republican member of Congress
Madison Cawthorn, who is now coyly threatening
bloodshed if the elections remain, as he calls
it, rigged. This is absolutely horrifying
stuff from any citizen of the United States.
But this is an elected member of Congress,
Congressman Madison Cauthen, Republican from North
Carolina, on Sunday. This is just a couple of days
ago falsely suggested that elections in the United
States are rigged and said there will be bloodshed
if the country's electoral system continues on its
current path. Given the context of January 6th,
that should be seen and treated as a threat,
Cawthorn, a freshman lawmaker and pro Trump star
of the right, made the remarks during an event
at the Macon County Republican Party headquarters
in Franklin, North Carolina, on Sunday night. The
video has been taken offline as of Tuesday morning
from the event's Facebook page. But we have it.
We have the video. And here is Madison Cawthorn.
Threatening bloodshed should be expelled
from Congress and investigated by the FBI.
He might end up getting reelected
in November of 2002. Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Everything that we're sitting here
talking about, we're all so passionate right now.
The things that we are wanting to fight for. It
doesn't matter if our votes don't count because,
you know, if our election systems continue to
be rigged and continue to be stolen, then it's
going to lead to one place and bloodshed.
Speaker 1: So remember, it's a false premise. The
election wasn't stolen. Joe Biden won by quite a
few, quite a few electoral votes, as many as Trump
won by in 2016 and by far more in the popular
vote. But he is basing on that false premise,
the idea that there will be bloodshed.
Speaker 6: And I will tell you,
as much as I am willing to defend our
liberty at all costs. There's nothing
that I dread doing more than having to
pick up arms against a fellow American.
Why? The way that we can have recourse
against if we all passionately demand
that we have elections, security in all 50 states.
Speaker 1: So that clip was ultimately taken down
because it obviously doesn't look good. The
FBI should be investigating Madison Cawthorn,
understand the totality of Cawthorn. He has said
that he is sometimes armed on the floor of the
House of Representatives since metal detectors
have been put in. I don't know what the latest
is on that. He attempted to bring a gun onto a
plane, tried to carry it on with him, said, oops,
that was a mistake, and now is saying there is
going to be bloodshed if our elections continue to
be stolen, which of course, they are not. The FBI
should investigate. This is Trumpy and Terror. And
I don't know how anybody can feel even remotely
optimistic about the future of this country
when we have elected officials sworn to
uphold the Constitution who are talking about
taking up arms against other Americans, it's
sort of what the calls are coming from inside
the house moment here. This is language that
historically you would expect from two places,
one from actual fascist dictatorships, or
second, in situations where the government has
actually lost its legitimacy and its ability to
have an election. This is not the second one,
right. As far as elections go, our government
does many bad things. But as far as elections go,
we still have elections that are
basically fair elections, meaning
I wonder if this is a guy who has delusions of the
first one, a fascist dictatorship, dictatorship.
It is not just that these clowns and I'm talking
about Madison Cawthorn and Marjorie Taylor Green
and Lauren Bowerbird and Louie Gohmert and Matt
Gates and the whole list of them. It's not just
that they're unqualified for the job of being
elected officials. Their rhetoric is completely
anti-American and borderline traitorous. And not
only do they have no business being lawmakers,
these are folks that should be under investigation
for their allusions to violence that they
continually make. So that's Madison Cawthorn
and we're going to continue to follow it